ce matin les résidents qui retiennent
leur souffle alors que la tempête
tropicale barreur et qui devrait se
transformer en ouragan est sur le point
de toucher terre avec des vents d'une
grande intensité mais c'est surtout la
quantité d'eau qui inquiète toujours
traumatisant pour cette région là qui a
été ravagée par l'ouragan katrina en
renault a maintenu hier à gagner avec
moi bonjour bonjour alors que ce soit
tempête tropicale ou un ouragan non on
verra concept
ce matin c'est quand même un événement
météo extrêmement dangereux
si oui c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est pas à
cause de la force de ses vents c'est
surtout à cause de la quantité d'eau
qu'elle transporte que la tempête
transporte avec elle
il faut dire que présentement les trois
entrées d'eau importante en louisiane le
premier ça vient de derrière russe à une
fleuve mississippi qui a un niveau
anormalement élevé pour un mois de
juillet présentement niveau et à cinq
mètres alors que d'habitude on le
retrouve plus autour de 12 mètres à ce
temps ci de l'année
est ce aussi dus à des inondations
printanières exceptionnel que au mois de
mars des rhénans tout le midwest
américain dont le mississippi s'est pas
encore remis l'autre élément c'est la
pluie donc depuis mercredi dernier la
région ont reçu 200 mm de pluie et l'on
s'attend en 250 supplémentaires d'ici la
fin de la fin de semaine et le troisième
élément c'est long deux tempêtes que
berry amène avec elle ce sila la montée
rapide du niveau de la mer qui
accompagne sion de tempête quand le son
vin souffle littéralement l'eau de la
mer à l'intérieur des terres et tous ces
éléments combinés ça vient s'ajouter un
système hydrologique est déjà saturé en
eau donc on pourrait se retrouver des
inondations importantes qui vont durer
des jours après le passage de berry qui
passent extrêmement lentement aussi donc
qui déversent des grandes quantités
d'eau en même temps est-ce qu'on peut
dire que tout ça c'est une situation
anormale
non mais sibérie se transforme en
ouragan ça va être la troisième fois
seulement en un siècle et demi qu'un
ouragan touche terre en louisiane à ce
temps ci de l'année donc c'est assez
surprenant mais on est quand même assez
tôt dans la saison des ouragans donc on
l'a pas vraiment tirer de conclusions
sur qu'est-ce qui est en train de se
passer là dessus par contre pour ce qui
est du niveau d'eau sont 6es anormal
d'abord le mississippi qui vient dire
des crues printanières historique
baisser ce genre de crue l'on sait
qu'elles vont être de plus en plus
courant tohoku au cours des prochaines
années
ces cinq mètres alors que normalement
c'est à 2
grosse différence ça va arriver plus
souvent à cause à cause des changements
climatiques qui vont amener beaucoup
plus d'eau de pluie dans ce système
hydrologique là et l'autre province et
les ouragans et les tempêtes tropicales
elle-même qui amène de plus en plus dont
on le vit avec les études que de plus en
plus depuis dans ce système là parce que
l'eau du golfe du mexique est de plus en
plus chaude donc ça fait plus en plus de
vapeur d'eau qui le moteur de ce système
là et l'atmosphère elle-même qui est de
plus en plus chaude peut elle aussi
accueillir de plus en plus de vapeur
d'eau et tout ça ça fait que ces
tempêtes le déversent plus de pluie mais
on a vu aussi que les ouragans avec les
années qui passent sont aussi de plus en
plus lent berry lui se déplace à environ
6 km h 3o dernière aux dernières mesures
et donc ça c'est un problème parce que
ça fait que toute cette pluie vaut
rester vous déversez plus longtemps au
même endroit et ça va causer les
inondations qu'on risque de voir avec
berry en ce moment et rappelez nous
pourquoi la louisiane est si sensible
aux inondations mais ce sacoche du type
de sol de la géologie de la région le
meilleur exemple c'est la vie de la
nouvelle orléans qui se trouve dont le
niveau dépendra on se trouve dans la
ville et entre 1 et 3 mètres sous le
niveau de la mer c'est une ville qui a
été construit sous 1 sur un marais faut
le rappeler est le sol de cette région
entre spongieux et donc se solde à sa
stabilité dépend de la part de sédiments
du mississippi et de l'eau des marais
elle même la force de construire des
digues des systèmes de drainage
on a coupé le sol de cette source
d'approvisionnement et là le seul a
commencé à s'affaisser donc depuis un
siècle
il ya 50% de la nouvelle orléans qui
s'est retrouvé son niveau de la mer et
la ville continue de s'enfoncer au
rythme de 1 cm chaque année avec la
hausse du niveau de la mer d'ici 2100
on s'attend à ce que la nouvelle orléans
se retrouve quatre mètres sous le niveau
de la mer et là c'est un gros test
aujourd'hui est-ce que les dés qu'on a
construite après katrina mounir le coup
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour éviter
que ça empire c'est des travaux qui ont
été faits pour 14 milliards de dollars
pour améliorer la situation
le problème c'est que ces digues là
elles ont des capacités fixait s'adapte
aux changements on peut pas refaire ça
chaque année à ce prix là mais avec ce
que j'ai dit plus tôt c'est dégueulasse
rompu bonne d'ici quelques années
donc là on essaie de faire des de
restaurer les zones humides qui ont de
meilleures capacités d'adaptation et
d'absorption donc les constructions
humaines dans une région comme la
louisiane où l'eau vive
de tous bords tous côtés des solutions
on en trouve de moins en moins quelle
désolation est fait pour que les gens
restent elles frappent et la part des
inondations majeures en tout cas on
continue de suivre ça bien sûr merci
beaucoup de nous ça fait plaisir à voir